[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je dis premier à février
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
il reste campé sur leurs positions une
métropole régionale sans suppression de
la petite couronne francilienne hier à
boulogne billancourt les présidents des
départements d'île de france se sont une
nouvelle fois réunis objectif contrer
les rumeurs sur la métropole du grand
paris alors que des a's annonce
officielle se font attendre
l'établissement est installé à voisins
le bretonneux depuis la rentrée 2010 est
le collège privé pour jeunes filles la
chêneraie propose un enseignement
tourner vers les arts pour en parler
nous recevons sa directrice isabelle
paris c'est romain champion professeur
de chant et puis le le meilleur ami à
des petits et un souvenir d'enfance pour
beaucoup le doudou est à l'honneur à
guyancourt
une exposition lui est consacrée
jusqu'au à 4 mars
reportage le préfet des yvelines serge
morvan a reçu à la presse ce matin à
versailles petit déjeuner pour aborder
l'ensemble des actualités du département
il était question bien sûr des
inondations qui touchent toujours le
territoire placé encore ce soir en
vigilance orange la décrue est amorcée
même si une nouvelle montée des eaux est
attendu ce week-end la crue qui a été
plus importantes que celles de juin 2016
sur la seine en aval de conflans sainte
honorine elle les précisions au micro de
nicolas landry et ben la crue a été
gonflé par les apports de l'oise et donc
de ce fait on est effectivement à des
niveaux de crues qui sont encore très
élevés la décrue en a atteint un premier
pic de crue mercredi mais savent à rome
ça va remonter certainement ce week-end
qui est au delà de ce qu'on avait connu
en juin 2016 alors que avant la
confiance avec l'oise
on est plutôt au même niveau de ce qu'on
avait connu en juin 2016
donc nous avons dû par contre procéder
par mesure de sécurité surtout au
déménagement
d'un site du centre hospitalier
intercommunal meulan les mureaux située
sur l'île du fort tout en gardant un
accueil nous allons nous sommes en train
d'affiner nos prévisions pour
certainement rouvrir les urgences de cet
hôpital
ce qui permettra de régler les cas les
plus urgents évidemment mais à la
réunion de ce matin qui a été également
l'occasion de dévoiler les derniers
chiffres de la délinquance à retenir une
baisse en 2010 est des atteintes aux
biens -8% sur les cambriolages et les
violences sexuelles
elles ont augmenté de 6% l'an passé elle
les autorités notent cependant une
libération de la parole avec plus de
dénonciation de faits est les semaines
passent les rassemblements se
ressemblent les annonces officielles
elles se font à toujours t'attendre sur
la métropole du grand paris alors pour
continuer à se faire entendre et les
présidents des départements d'île de
france se sont réunis une nouvelle fois
c'était hier à boulogne billancourt
ils répètent leurs messages pas de
suppression des départements est une
métropole à l'échelle de la région les
précisions avec ce sujet de nicolas
kirillovitch même lieu mêmes élus même
message le jeu des sept erreurs en
presque parfait pour ses discours à deux
semaines d'intervalle
qui sera capable de faire à notre place
tout ce que nous réalisons pourquoi
détruire ce qui marche pour rafistoler
ce qui ne marche pas les élus
d'ile-de-france ne lâchent pas leur
vision du grand paris alors que les
annonces du gouvernement se font
toujours attendre
pour eux la réforme de la métropole ne
peut entraîner la suppression des
départements et doit s'élargir à toute
la région un enjeu il estime crucial
pour le développement des territoires
des grands investissements ne se feront
pas avoir six ou dans la grande cour
ce fort en priorité c'est ce qu'on
appelle la petite couronne la petite
ceinture et on ne peut pas avoir au sein
de l'ile-de-france un nouveau
périphérique la grande couronne dont
nous faisons partie est une évidence et
une nécessité aujourd'hui pour un
équilibre ça nous permettrait également
d'éviter les mille feuilles qui sont
aujourd'hui difficiles à comprendre
invité d'honneur du rassemblement 500
élus locaux et des représentants de la
société civile
moi la notion des départements me parle
la notion de la région me parle la
notion de métropole me parle beaucoup
moins chefs d'entreprises responsables
d'associations partenaires sociaux ils
ont tous justifier l'importance du
département et tenter de mettre la
pression pour l'avenir et là on a voulu
que des chefs d'entreprise et
responsables associatifs et travailleurs
sociaux
bref qu'il celles et ceux qui savent
l'indispensable nécessité du département
puisse s'exprimer
je crois qu'ils ont fait avec leurs mots
et surtout avec leur exemple prochaine
action des départements d'île de france
mercredi 7 février avec une fermeture
des services publics
les décisions du gouvernement sont elles
attendues une semaine plus tard elle
était particulièrement menacée la ligne
18 verra bien le jour le grand paris
express et ses cinq nouveaux métros
seront réalisés en intégralité à la
ministre des transports elisabeth bornes
l'aurait confirmé par courrier aux élus
franciliens tracé validé reste
maintenant à confirmer les délais un
calendrier est plus réaliste devrait
être dévoilé en mars prochain la
livraison du premier tronçon de la ligne
18 pourrait notamment être retardée de
2024 à 2026 dans l'actualité également
une journée de mobilisation aujourd'hui
contre la réforme du bac et la sélection
à l'entrée des universités
c'est à l'appel de plusieurs syndicats
notamment du monde étudiant et vous
voyez à l'image les militants de l'unef
de l'université versailles saint quentin
en yvelines qui a préparé à leurs
banderoles avant de se rendre cet
après-midi à paris pour la manifestation
premier rassemblement depuis
l'instauration de la plateforme
d'admission après le bac parcours sup
propos recueillis par nicolas
kirillovitch pas nous on a une seule
chose à dire c'est ni tirage au sort ni
sélection s'ils avaient du tirage au
sort auparavant c'était une aberration
mais si elle avait lieu ce que l'état
n'investit pas assez dans l'enseignement
supérieur et qui a pas assez de places
dans les
à l'heure actuelle la section là pas du
tout régler ce problème il y aura
toujours pas assez de place ce que les
étudiants auront encore moins l'accès
aux études de leur choix demain
nous ce qu'on dit c'est ni tirage au
sort ni sélection investissements
massifs dans l'enseignement supérieur
une manifestation cet après midi à paris
qui aurait réuni selon les syndicats 10
mille personnes et deux invités m'ont
rejoint en plateau isabelle parize
bonsoir vous êtes la directrice du
collège la chêneraie à voisins le
bretonneux avec nous également en
plateau romain champion bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur le professeur de chant dans
l'établissement alors la chaîne reste un
collège privé hors contrat basé à
voisins le bretonneux est depuis la
rentrée 2010 est géré par une
association art college alors pour en
savoir plus je vous propose tout de
suite de regarder ce sujet de marylène
aya piccino et nicolas landry des arts
plastiques du champ du théâtre et que
des filles le collège privé pour jeunes
filles de la chaîne rai a déménagé du
chéné à voisins le bretonneux
depuis la rentrée 2010 est une vingtaine
d'élèves en uniforme sont inscrits de la
6e à la 3e ont fait quand même lui
matière de l'éducation nationale mais on
a en plus deux heures des théâtres par
semaine et quatre heures de chant et
on travaille comme ça on apprend des
chants un peu toutes les sortes
et on travaille aussi sur des dessins
doit par exemple on a fait des affiches
pour les journées portes ouvertes et on
en fait pour pour différentes occasions
alors pour des projets l'établissement
est centré sur l'art mais aussi la
religion avec des causeries mensuelles
thématiques pour assurer une formation
chrétienne les parents adhèrent à ce
programme et sont ravis de la non mixité
c'est un âge où les filles sont quand
même mur du doué et je pense que pour
les garçons c'est très mauvais d'être
avec des filles et je pense que pour les
filles elles développent bien plus leurs
qualités féminines en étant dans un
environnement surtout à cet âge là à
l'âge de l'adolescence de la puberté
c'est un âge qui est pas facile et voilà
donc pour moi le collège c'est très
important qu'il soit pas dans une classe
mixte un projet éducatif bien différent
des autres établissements pour des frais
d'inscription de 350 euros par mois
alors isabelle paris ça a été dit dans
le sujet le collège propose un projet
éducatif différents notamment il
s'adresse exclusivement aux filles
pourquoi avoir fait ce choix tout
simplement parce qu'à cet âge là entre
11 et 14 ans garçons et filles n'ont pas
les mêmes centres d'intérêts du coup
c'est plus facile pour nous enseignants
de maintenir l'attention de nos élèves
et même de les enthousiasmes et ça veut
dire qu'une fille entourée de garçons au
collège pourrait pas réussir selon vous
ceci tout à fait mais c'est surtout que
pour nous professeurs enseignants nous
abordons des thèmes qui vont intéresser
davantage les filles c'est tout alors
c'est un collège privé hors contrat
ça a été dit également dans le sujet
qu'est ce que ça change concrètement
dans la construction des des programmes
et des emplois du temps en fait ça ne
change rien nous enseignons aux élèves
le programme officiel de l'éducation
nationale en gardant les 26 heures
d'enseignement qui sont obligatoires et
par semaine et on dispense en 6 à 8
heures d'ateliers artistiques chant arts
plastiques théâtre c'est à dire quoi au
sortir de ce collège les filles sont
bien armés pour pour arriver au lycée
tout à fait tout à fait enfin c'est le
but très bien alors on l'a dit un
établissement qui est résolument tournée
vers vers les arts pourquoi c'est
important cet enseignement d or parce
que bon on re découvre actuellement
l'importance de l'art dans le
développement personnel de chaque enfant
surtout à la charrière du collège et
cette pédagogie père nous permet de
répondre aussi à la demande de la mise
en place des hauts-pays enseignements
pratiques interdisciplinaire ans romain
champion ou quatre professeurs de chant
où est votre point de vue qu'est ce que
ça apporte concrètement d'avoir cet
enseignement artistique d'un collège
très pragmatiquement en fait ce dont on
se rend compte c'est que les matières
artistiques sont pourvoyeurs de métier
plus tard donc faut pas oublier ça d'une
part ce que ce que madame barry ça dit
c'est que ça participe à l'équilibré
c'est un enseignement qui a fait cas
toujours fait partie de l'enseignement
des enfants et d'autres tard
au sortir de
des études c'est pourvoyeur de métier il
faut pas l'oublier quand même lors d'un
de ces heurts bien sûr c'est le chant on
l'a vu dans le reportage les élèves
pratiquent notamment et chants religieux
puisque le collège en rappel a aussi une
dimension religieuse chrétienne ce qui
est aussi des vous enseigne aussi des
chants profanes express est au programme
alors tout à fait par exemple cette
année les programmes
on a commencé avec un programme sur un
compte égyptien donc tout à fait profane
à la période de noël bien évidemment on
a fait autour de autour de la fête de
noël et dans le reste de l'année on
prévoit de faire un spectacle autour
d'une oeuvre de molière les femmes
savantes et une farce du moyen-âge
envoyé on essaye d'être tout à fait
éclectique il faut quand même rappeler
que le la musique religieuse fait partie
intégrante de la culture que européenne
beaucoup beaucoup de deux oeuvres
religieuses et on défend toutes ces
musiques quelle qu'elle soit et en outre
la musique le chant quels sont les
autres arts qui sont enseignées au
collège la chêneraie elles jouent elles
font du théâtre donc et puis arts
plastiques c'est à dire des elle dessine
est aussi construisent des décors qui
vont servir aux différentes pièces que
nous allons présenter ce n'est sur le
parcours au collège à vont pouvoir
suivre tout ou césar les élèves où elles
ont un choix à faire des choix d'options
par exemple l'instant elles n'ont pas le
choix il faut tout en totalité parce que
nous sommes encore assez peu nombreux et
une fois que nous aurons un avantage
grossi laon elle rompt plus un choix à
faire
elle se spécialiseront dans un des trois
armées elles ont quand même les trois à
suivre alors une question importante qui
est celle de l'uniforme et les filles du
collège la chaîne rai porte un uniforme
au moment même il ya ces débats aussi
dans le public faut-il revenir ou pas à
l'uniforme jean-michel blantyre le le
ministre de l'éducation nationale en
tout cas poser le débat pourquoi vous au
collège
fallait il fallait que les filles les
élèves portent un uniforme parce que
d'une part parce que c'est donc un
collège artistique et personnellement je
trouve que c'est beau de porter un
uniforme
cela donne une certaine harmonie et en
plus nous avons choisi des couleurs
gaies un gris clair et puis vers
turquoise donc voilà c'est un mineur un
uniforme qui leur plaît voilà
et puis aussi on souhaite créer une
cohérence au delà des inégalités
sociales
dernière question très rapide au sortir
du collège les élèves s'oriente vers
aussi encore du privé ou est ce qu'elles
retournent au public alors c'est varié
variés d'accord tout est possible et
pour plus d'informations sur le collège
la chêneraie vous pouvez vous rendre sur
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci à vous deux isabelle
parisse et romain champion d'avoir été
avec nous je le rappelle respectivement
directrice et professeur de chant de ce
collège la chêneraie qui est située
depuis la rentrée 2010 est à voisins le
bretonneux
ils sont en formation bar nano lycée
d'hôtellerie de guyancourt et ont mis en
avant leur technique et leur créativité
sept élèves vont tenter de se qualifier
hier pour un concours international de
création de cocktails à base de calvados
un alcool qu'il devait associer un
légume
aurélie rond a suivi le concours gestes
précis et concentration pour ces élèves
du lycée d'hôtellerie de guyancourt qui
tente de décrocher leur place pour un
concours international de création de
cocktails
un trophée qui s'adresse aussi bien aux
barmen professionnels qu'aux élèves
ils sont notamment jugés sur leur
technique on doit exécuter de telle ou
telle façon il faut bien au niveau du
shaker au niveau 2 de son matériel etc
il ya beaucoup de respect de règles
à suivre il faut suivre ces règles pour
que tout fonctionne correctement
autre critère pour s'imposer l'ogou le
cocktail doit obligatoirement contenir
un alcool le calvados aime également
imposé cette année les légumes
l'apparence la rom ou encore la
décoration sont scrutés à la loupe pour
moi celui ci manque d'équilibré ils ont
bien compris le thème de cette année qui
était le légume mai
celui ci est
le légume prend bien trop le dessus par
rapport au calvados et l' équilibre
n'est pas au bout d'une heure et demie
le verdict tombe c'est mathilde et son
cocktail pink même à base de sirop de
vanille de jus de pommes de calvados et
de jus de betterave qui obtient le plus
de points en fait ça me faisait penser
l'insight comme rmc quand quand j'étais
petit stade justement il y avait de la
pomme et de la betterave et du coup
voilà et puis la couleur est sympa donc
je me suis pour un comptable ça pourrait
être bien fin mars
l'étudiante défendra les couleurs de
guyancourt lors de la finale nationale à
quoi un mot de sport nous sommes à moins
de huit mois de la ryder cup 2018 la
compétition de golf la plus médiatique
au monde vous le savez sans doute la 42e
édition se déroulera pour la toute
première fois en france et au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
guyancourt michael et demi d'euros
étaient sur place cette semaine pour
rencontrer l'un des organisateurs je
suis avec paul hermitage le directeur du
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous sommes à
huit mois de la ryder cup paul est ce
que tout est prêt pour cette ryder cup
la réponse est non mais tout est sous
contrôle non il reste encore du travail
mais en est on est bien parti vraiment
on est évidemment concentrer la tête
bien sur les épaules pour
transformer l'essai et puis réussir
l'événement donc il reste encore du
travail mais ça va essayer cette affaire
juste by encore bien sûr des détails
tels que transports le plan de transport
les parkings des choses comme ça il ya
des petits éléments qui peuvent bouger
encore sur la planification des travaux
qu'on n'a pas assez anticipé ou les
petits soucis comme ça
par rapport à tout ce qui est vente de
billetterie
la quantité vraiment le volume de
personnes qui vont venir tout ça ça
reste à confirmer donc et encore deux
trois petites choses qui peuvent bouger
mais en gros le plan est maintenant et
je dirais 90% figé le parcours est prêt
à recevoir c'était preuve le troisième
événement mondial télévisée oui oui le
parcours nous conforte en ce moment on
m'a fait des gros travaux que vous avez
suivi en 2015 2016
et avec cet hiver il perd plus vieux
qu'on vit actuellement on est ravi de
comment se comporte le parcours il est
toujours ouvert on essaie que sur pied
c'est assez impressionnant quand même le
travaux de drainage comme ça a été une
réussite quand on compare nos deux
autres parcours qui malheureusement sans
un petit peu plus goukoye il ait eu
beaucoup de pluie ces derniers mois ici
sur la région parisienne est ce que ça a
joué sur le terrain
oui oui énormément ça nous retarde pas
dans notre préparation
ça nous a permis même de détecter des
petits points faibles je donne un
exemple sur le parcours il ya ce qu'on
appelle des bunkers des bunkers cd
obstacle de sable convoi près des
grilles nous sur les phares ou et on en
a vu deux trois qui ont qui avait du mal
à drainer et donc on les refait
carrément là en ce moment tant que ça
c'est même un bonus grâce au à la météo
même si on aimerait bien voir un peu de
soleil et un peu de sexe
sur le plan sportif et si vous vous
sentez que la tension monte est-ce que
les capitaine de ryder cup viennent ici
au golf national pour observer le
terrain prendre un peu le pouls de la
compétition oui on a eu l'avènement uni
au togo
on a comme on dit le plaisir d'avoir jim
furyk deux fois maintenant
je ne suis pas au courant quand est-ce
qu'ils vont revenir mais je suis sûr
qu'ils vont revenir de façon du mur etc
a dit qu'il allait envoyer une
invitation à ses joueurs potentiels pour
jouer l'open de france va pas dire
qu'ils vont tous venir la chesnaie open
de france loin de là donc c'est parce
que je suis en train de dire mais je
pense que leur focus est maintenant sûr
sur mieux connaître le parcours et des
installations
ceci dit
les joueurs aussi comment ça a monté en
voit une crème qui monte au dessus du
lait au niveau de l'europe il ya six
mois on se disait ouhlala une forte
équipe américaine avec tous ces jeunes
qu'est ce qu'on va faire contre eux on
avait quelques doutes mais plus puis
maintenant on se dirait même que
l'équilibré est tombé du côté d'eux
européen l'open de france 2010 vie ce
sera le premier test pour le golf
national ont vu de cette ryder cup qui
sera fin septembre ici à l'open de
france et maintenant dans la
configuration à schonach oleg series
avec avec l'european tour on l'a déjà
vécu et ans et en vain et en plus on
al'avantage de travail avec les mêmes
organisateurs ont les mêmes équipes
qu'on connaît très très bien on s'entend
très bien donc la difficulté cette année
c'est de livrer les deux événéments dans
un timing très court c'est à dire que on
a enfin rejoint l'open de france et fin
septembre dans trois quatre mois plus
tard la ryder cup tant qu'il ya une
logistique de montage de dégrad un
montage du chapiteau au montage de
structures qui va commencer à se jouer à
partir de fin avril sur le site
mais tout ça est bien maintenant
planifier
c'est même quelque part pour nous tous
un soulagement parce qu'on va commencer
à construire la ryder cup avant l'open
de france tandis que peut-être avec deux
différents promoteurs on aurait eu
l'open de france à démonter totalement
et à remonter totalement le
ada sur le plan sportif c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose est
ce qu'il y aura des français ici au golf
national pour cette ryder cup
je dirais qu'on a des espoirs peut-être
qu'on n'avait pas il ya quelques mois
maintenant je répète ce que thomasg
bjorn dit et que on pense tous c'est que
il va vraiment choisir la meilleure
équipe donc il y aura pas de la place
pour un français juste parce que la
ryder cup et en france du côté des
américains il y en a un qui fait
beaucoup parler de lui en ce moment
c'est tiger woods tiger woods qui est de
retour au plus haut niveau on peut le
dire il a passé le cut
justement le week-end dernier il revient
bien il sera dans l'équipe
il revient bien il revient je dirais
même en toute beauté
il a rajeuni pour moi je dirais qu'il a
5 ans 5 à 7 ans de moins
il est souriant ce qu'on n'avait pas
l'habitude de voir ces derniers temps on
voit bien que il prend plaisir
il est concentré il est juste dans ses
propos aussi sur ses propres actions
mais on sent une motivation alors je
sais pas si sa motivation et personnel
pour sa carrière en tant que
professionnel aussi sa motivation et
pour la ryder cup mais peu importe il
est de retour
il est là et on a tout espoir à l'avoir
au golf national pour seulement la
deuxième fois depuis qu'on existe une
ryder cup avec tiger woods c'est
forcément une ryder cup réussi alors
forcément mais c'est pas nécessaire
nécessairement qu'il est obligé d'être
là je maintenant que je vois la
puissance de cet événement une ryder cup
avec tiger woods c'est la cerise une
ryder cup peut sans tiger woods c'est un
événement magique
merci beaucoup paul hermitage et la
ryder cup c'est dans huit mois ici au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce sera du 28
au 30 septembre 2018 suite et fin à
présent du dossier de la rédaction
consacrer la culture urbaine dans les
yvelines zoom sur le graffiti cet art
urbain venu de new york a pris forme en
france dans les années à 80 certains en
font leur métier comme happy originaire
de ben une rencontre signée par mélanie
poker
la bombe de peinture et un mur dans un
lieu abandonné api grave depuis près de
15 ans le mur un terrain de jeu pour ce
jeune evelyn waugh le truc ici à plein
de plein de black book mais chaque j'ai
retrouvé tout à l'heure en fait se
sceller des choses que j'ai retrouvée
qui sont les lélés je crois que c'est
mon tout premier ce qu'on appelle un
black book en fait c'est un drap bookers
et des lettrages tout commence ici à
benne dans la maison familiale
le street art tapis pierre antoine
ménard de son vrai nom le découvre par
son grand frère et la révélation un mur
et une photo en souvenir une passion qui
le fait ensuite travaillé en atelier
quand tu es revenu de bienvenue dans le
grand voyage il est parti sur barcelone
je crois dans les années 2000 quelque
chose comme ça et en fait il a monté une
boutique de ce prêt et moi je suis allé
lui rendre visite en vacances je devais
avoir 15 16 ans et j'ai découvert à
barcelone toute une équipe qui est
devenu mon collectif plus tard après je
suis revenu ici en banlieue parisienne
et après plus tard sur paris et là j'ai
découvert le graffiti le vrai graffitis
les tunnels du métro tout ça va et après
après ses noces est un peu c'est un peu
comme une drogue
quand on est piqué ben devient un lieu
de stockage 15 ans de travail et plus
d'une centaine d'oeuvres réalisées
aujourd'hui il crée ils recherchent ils
dessinent à bobigny
mêlant culture des années 80 références
classiques la bombe
mais plus on sale outils j'essaie d'une
consistance de deux murs un peu à mes
toiles outre avec de l'acrylique
la peinture de chantiers beaucoup de
beaucoup de 2,2 technique populaire en
fait j'utilise un produit qu'une espèce
de latex aussi pour superposer des
couches de couleurs et venir gratter que
les couches d'eau soit par s ce prêt de
la pastel grâce beaucoup d'encre voilà
un peu un peu tout ce que je trouve
longtemps considérées comme marginales
dégradants et illégale le street art
investit aujourd'hui les galeries api
vit de son art vente de toiles et
expositions comme ici à la celle saint
cloud avec le collectif 1980 il a
l'intelligence en fait avec finesse
d'amener l'histoire de l'art dans le
street art donc y rattachent un peu les
choses dans le collectif il ya plusieurs
artistes qui ont fait les beaux-arts lui
n'a pas fait les beaux-arts mais là ils
puissent vraiment son énergie là donnant
même s'il explose api n'a pas abandonné
le graffiti et la rue alors ouvrez bien
les yeux pour découvrir les trois
lettres de sa signature
[Musique]
allez on retombe en enfance pour
refermer ce journal les doudous sous
toutes leurs coutures sont à l'honneur à
guyancourt est des artistes ont réalisé
à des créations avec la complicité des
habitants
une expo à voir jusqu'au 4 mars
découverte sur ces images de patrick
jacques de dixmude et la voix de camille
lambert
[Musique]
un doudou c'est plus qu'un copain de jeu
c'est un véritable compagnon de vie qui
soit peluche animal petits monstres
il sèche les larmes plus petit et
rassure les enfants un ami
ça évoque je pense pour n'importe quelle
personne là bas son enfance évidemment
après en tant que parent bas
on a une deuxième vie avec nos propres
aux enfants sur le doubs moi j'ai pas eu
de doudou nounours j'avais juste un tee
shirt que je trais fouillaient voilà et
c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu mettre en
avant le textile parce que je pense
qu'un doudou c'est pas forcément une
peluche ça pète tout toutes sortes de
petits bouts de couverture de t-shirts
une exposition réalisée par une dizaine
d'artistes avec la participation des
habitants de guyancourt pour accompagner
le visiteur bagatelle est colossal de
doudou imaginé par les enfants des
écoles de nos villes
nano nos mascottes bagatelle est
colossal voilà qui ont été faits par
marie-claire duyse une bénévole car
produit vraiment à l'identique les
dessins des enfants
on avait plus de 500 dessins donc
c'était très très difficile de choisir
expérience visuelle tactile et
sensorielle pour pour jouer au mieux
dans ce monde de douceur les visiteurs
sont invités à déambuler sans chaussures
un retour en enfance à l'insouciance
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal à
revoir sur notre application mobile tv
soixante dix huit très bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]